hello everyone we are with Michael
Carrick offski a spokesperson for the
Grantchester he's also a member of the
advisory board with some exciting news
Michael tell us what the Grantchester
has in store for 2018 for 2018 we'll
only have the same lineup of the
tournament's that we had previous years
and we have one more exciting news
because we decided that we would like to
modify the format we decided that it
would bring more excitement
if the climax of the tour will be in the
last tournament in London so the top
four players will play matches to
determine the winner of the grand cheer
story now these top four players are
actually playing a knockout as opposed
to four of them playing each other in a
round-robin format correct that's
correct top four players from other
tournaments will compete to determine
the winner of the grand chest or they
will play two semifinal matches which
would include classical games rapid and
blitz games as well the winner of each
semifinal match will go to compete for
the title of the Grantchester
champion so it sounds like we're having
more of a sports forum you like the NBA
or the NHL very exciting a culminating
final event in London a great way to
start the new year 2018 shaking up the
Grantchester
you